is there time for love there is time for
love I'm thinking banana of love we take
rock and love to a whole new level now
think about this we got Brett's brew we
could have Brett's banana bread right
yeah bread that's why I love you both
right there how are you doing are you
holding up
honestly first of all I want to say to
you as we're just getting started I hope
both you are safe and healthy to you
your friends your family everybody and
here's how I've done it first slow to
everyone out there I want to say to
everyone on the front line all of our
first responders doctors nurses the
drivers the restaurant employees
everyone keeping us rocking and stocking
up the grocery stores you really realize
how thankful we are for everything they
do putting himself at risk and for me
myself just keeping totally positive and
this is what I mean for a lot of people
mentally mentally staying positive in
the game and then and then all of a
sudden that helps you physically
spiritually and I'm in the highest
highest risk category as a diabetic so
I'm a lifelong diabetic five injections
a day since I've been kid so just
staying safe with my family and kids and
everybody and following the guidelines
so where exactly are you and by the way
are you in a a music room can you kind
of paint this the pictures so you know
in the background this is a part of the
studio room in my at the range in
Arizona and I go back and forth between
Los Angeles and here it gives me some
room to go out there and have some fun
and rip it up but not getting sick are
you with your kids who you holed up with
yeah kids and then I travel like boy in
the bubble I get in the car that's it
and other than the masking and about
eight pairs of gloves for the gas pump
that's it and you said you're on the
ranch is there anything specifically
you're doing to help pass the time any
new hobbies you've gotten into
absolutely I've built a full motocross
track so I've been recent dirt bike
since I was a kid I gave you a pro-am
when I was young so I still do I've got
the go cards I painted my whole sport
court I never realized what a hoarder I
was I started pulling everything out
it's given me a true opportunity to be
grateful to focus on family and
we clean it up a little bit how is this
global pandemic affecting your career
I'm the kind of guy I like being on the
move and I tour almost year-round and I
love it besides doing the solo tour
dates poison was going out on the road
with Def Leppard and Motley Crue and
Joan Jett for all the stadiums and they
all everything was sold out as a
musician it affects your speed very
because that's what we love to do we
love to go out there and play music and
have a great time with the fans all the
meet and greets everything so without a
doubt that is tough and when these
guidelines finally cominis this comes to
pass and it's the right time I cannot
wait and not wait to get back out on the
road and play music
[Applause]
no you definitely please the fans last
night being unmasked as the banana your
music royalty you have your pick of
whatever you want to do what made you
join the masked singer a couple reasons
it's when I'm watching it as a fan and
as a viewer it's positive you know
everybody under yours having fun the
viewers are having fun the fans are
having fun social media we all get to
play him which our detective you know
sir all and they're looking at our son
as I choose songs leg sighs so you're
mixing that and then the insane costumes
and I'll tell you what I was honored
when they asked me to come do it I was
in the middle of touring and I said
we're just have to move and fix some
stuff and I said if you'll let me pick
out a costume give me a couple options I
know what I'd like to do I am in there
and I'll give a thousand percent
what were the runner-up costumes what
were you deciding between raisi predator
lost uh you know so I could be woman
whipping it around and having a great
time
and uh so crazy predators sort of look
and then all of a sudden it hit me I
thought that's gonna if I make a couple
moves and love the same a visa nice
Eadie's here come out singing some
Aerosmith or something like that I'm
like they're gonna hit they're gonna get
me right away so as a diabetic there's a
couple reasons a banana
is yeah thank you you have banana right
there and you get for you as well yeah
banana I move in with you guys right now
an astronaut outfit I wear the banana
mask potassium ready for you I'm sorry
continue being diabetic of bananas part
of my everyday life
right true story I come from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania so the color yellow works
for the Steelers for the Pirates
Penguins it just worked on everyone our
audience is always fascinated by the
behind the scenes of it all I want to
know if you can tell us a secret whether
it's about your costume or about
something performance or
production-oriented
that you would not know if we had just
tuned in and watched on TV they are so
unbelievably tight about secrecy like
when you show up you you don't leave
your house unless you're Darth Vader I
mean you have a mask
gloves they don't even let you have to
have socks on that they can't be see
your ankles you know because people out
on the street trying to get photos
because the best thing is a spoiler you
know what I mean I knew almost everyone
on production here from doing different
shows from rock loved apprentice to all
this different stuff right reisel I'm
walking by people that had just recently
been on the road with me as crew members
that were doing
lightening rigging so they're up there
rigging the lights and I'm done a lot
how are you doing handshake hug kind of
guy and that was the toughest part of
this whole show was not just don't up
and talking to people you cannot speak
you go from one room to the next room
you're not talking I was like a
real-life Avenger I was like Peter
Parker and spider-man Wednesday marks
the 10-year anniversary of your brain
hemorrhage what do you remember from
that experience 10 years ago
zero idea that it would ever lineup when
the exact same time as a 10 year I don't
say celebration 10 year celebration of
life and after the serac my brain
hemorrhage they were operating on my
brain while I was singing knocking on
heaven's door on West Coast time so
that's when I was dim with the brain
bleed and they were doing everything
they could to save my life and Here I am
as a human banana singing knocking on
heaven's door and it's just to be honest
with you when I reflect on it it is such
an amazing thankful grateful feeling to
be here talking with you talking with
both of you and and watch that happen at
the same time it gives you chills it's a
it's really a crazy moment your
daughters were really really young when
that happened I mean how did that make
you feel when I love being a dad I love
my daughters the rain in Georgia no one
they were young that was part of my
fight the minute I knew the second I
knew I came out of the coma and the
operation and I knew I had a chance of
surviving I was a thousand percent they
clean stopped me even the doctors like
we can't get this guy's I mean if I knew
I could make it I was going how is your
health today thank you for asking I feel
awesome
again lifelong diabetic and been taking
five or six injections a day since I've
been six years old and I looked at every
day like I said with gratitude is a
blessing I want to compliment you
because you're on top of the world right
now you had success on the masked singer
your career is in its peak you're a
family man you've got to ask is there
time for love there is time for love I'm
thinking banana of love we take rock and
love to a whole new level
think about this we got Brett's brew we
could have Brett's banana bread right
yeah so I love you both right there
and what we do think of the old
throwback 70 shows of like the dating
game in stellar didn't know the person
so imagine you're in some kind of outfit
just throw this out there and then they
have to love you for your personality
everyone says that but no one really
means this would actually you would have
to be loved as a masked human being and
I'm actually like you as a person and
then you hope when the mask comes off
the other part of the chemistry works so
clean of love so like the masked singer
but instead of a singing competition a
dating competition oh yeah I'm just
throwing it I say we won't we all free
whip this up thanks supporting tonight
how things happen right here right can
you confirm are you single
I cannot confirm or deny oh you are you
are open to finding love on TV again
it's out well it's not let me say this
let's just say I'm a family man let's
just say I would be a great host of
others I would be great at giving advice
that they should either listen to or
completely ignore if they're smart and
then they won't have great relationships
I think you just brought yourself up a
pilot in quarantine well I'm just saying
it's happening right here we're doing it
this rocks we are gonna have the most
awesome kick-ass time it's so cool
especially to see your daughter rains
rise to fame as such a gorgeous
supermodel
thank you being the father of two very
gorgeous girls how are you handling all
that are they allowed to date are you
tough on any potential suitors I'm going
to say this I've learned all my
negotiating skills by having two teenage
daughters I've learned how to negotiate
first for reigning Elizabeth she is
amazing old soul and yes she is out
there dating having fun she's in Sports
Illustrated as a model and doing the
LSATs and Georgia blue is a unbelievably
like myself she has this soul that is
driven she's a songwriter she's a singer
she wants to act and I said all this I
just give them encouragement and hope is
a dad that you've showed him enough of
how to treat people with respect be
great but also you should got
something's wrong you get a sixth sense
about something it's not great you're at
a place that's bad I said you got to act
on it and but with Georgia she just
wrote the single unbroken with me and
she stood at that piano and really
played this out and wrote it and so for
Georgia and for rain like I said I'm
blessed and Christy is amazing but hope
that gave him enough tools to be able to
go through life and navigate Charlie do
you think that his daughters have
watched Rock of Love I have they I don't
think they have you know they're
sneaking that in
[Music]